Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
What is an acoustic filter?
Well, it is an arbitrarily shaped object that
takes a sound as an input, and outputs a different
sound.
These filters have some really amazing applications
that you'll hear about in a minute.
In this work, a novel technique is proposed
to automatically design such filters.
It works by building an arbitrarily shaped
object as a set of connected tiny resonators,
and chooses appropriate sizes and setups for
each of these elements to satisfy a prescribed
set of acoustic properties.
Instead of resorting to a lengthy and flimsy
trial and error phase, we can use physics
to simulate what would happen if we were to
use a given arrangement in reality.
Again, one of those works that have a deep
connection to the real world around us.
Absolutely amazing.
The goal can be to eliminate the peaks of
the sound of a car horn or an airplane engine,
and we can achieve this objective by means
of optimization.
The proposed applications we can divide into
three main categories:
The first is identifying and filtering noise
attenuation components for a prescribed application,
to which we can also refer to as muffler design.
In simpler words, we are interested in filtering
or muffling the peaks of a known signal.
Designing such objects is typically up to
trial and error and in this case, it is even
harder because we're interested in a wider
variety of shape choices other than exhaust
pipes and tubes that are typically used in
the industry.
Second, designing musical instruments is hard,
and unless we design them around achieving
a given acoustic response, we'll likely end
up with inharmonious gibberish.
And this method also supports designing musical
instruments with, hmm, well, non-conventional
shapes.
Well, this is as non-conventional as it gets
I'm afraid.
And also, that is about the most harmonious
sound I've heard coming out of the rear end
of a hippo.
And third, this work opens up the possibility
of making hollow objects that are easy to
identify by means of acoustic tagging.
Check out this awesome example that involves
smacking these 3d printed piggies.
If you feel like improving your kung fu in
math, there are tons of goodies such as transmission
matrices, the Helmholtz equation, oh my!
The paper and the talk slides are amazingly
well written, and yes, you should definitely
have a look at them.
Let us know in the comments section if you
have some ideas for possible applications
beyond these ones, we love to read your take
on these works.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!